Samwell Tarly is more than just your average
loyal sidekick. Sure, he's loyal, honest,
and his heart of gold is too nice for this
world. But there's more to him than that.
In fact, Sam might just be the most important
Game of Thrones character of all. Season six's
finale episode dropped a giant Easter Egg
seemingly putting him at the center of...everything.
Oh, and just in case you weren't aware...spoilers
ahead.
What Sam Saw in the Citadel
When Sam, Gilly, and the baby finally arrived
in Oldtown, he got his first look at that
jaw-dropping library. And we spotted a special
something lingering above him: a spherical
chandelier system...that's awfully similar
to the astrolabe that shines in the show's
intro credits. That's right, the glowing golden
orb that comes into focus and kicks off every
episode had always seemed like something of
a lovely—but unimportant—visual before.
But now that it's been seen hanging in the
Citadel's massive library, its purpose might
be getting clearer...
Sam's Song of Ice and Fire?
As pointed out by an article from TV Guide,
George R. R. Martin, author of The Song of
Ice and Fire novels the show is based on,
has long admitted to being inspired by that
other double-RR-middle-named fantasy legend:
J.R.R. Tolkien, and his iconic Lord of the
Rings series. Samwell Tarly is thought to
be a tribute to Tolkien's character with a
similar name: Samwise Gamgee. That Sam ended
up being pretty important, as he was ultimately
given the task of finishing the story of "the
one ring to rule them all" and how it was
destroyed by Frodo.
"The last pages are for you Sam."
Martin has famously promised that his own
story ending would reflect Tolkien's "bittersweet"
ending style. So will Samwell Tarly do for
The Song of Ice and Fire what Samwise Gamgee
did for those little guys and the jewelry?
Does he write the story of Jon Snow versus
the White Walkers at the Citadel, under the
light of the big golden orb?
Is he the reason that book six missed its
damn deadline?
Research to the Rescue
Forget the fact that Daenerys Targaryen is
on her way to oust Mad Queen Cersei from the
Iron Throne. And that Jon Snow has been declared
King in the North and may have earned the
jealous ire of his sister-slash-cousin Sansa
Stark—and Littlefinger. Those are but battles
in the grand scheme of things. The true war,
of course, will come once the Night King figures
out a way to get his army of White Walkers
past the Wall. And Sam's access to Oldtown's
bevy of books may help him find a more efficient
way for people to kill the undead.
Building a Better Dragonglass
Sam's killed a White Walker himself with a
dragonglass dagger, so he already knows the
strength and resilience of the enemy's forces
and obsidian's effect on them. He also knows
about the stockpile of dragonglass in the
island of Dragonstone, thanks to the late
Stannis Baratheon. But the North's forces
are outnumbered, and the Walkers are tireless,
fast, and bloodthirsty. So, really, it might
be on Sam to discover a better way to defeat
those seemingly unkillable forces of darkness.
Could his good-hearted nature help convince
Daenerys to lend her dragons to the cause?
Because that might be super helpful.
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know if you think Sam is as important
as we do...